on high alert but in protective posture
Israeli forces near Lebanon have been
pulled back from their border positions
in recent days as they wait for a
promised strike by Hezbollah in response
to recent Israeli attacks and now Israel
is upping the pressure on both Lebanon
and Hezbollah it's released what it says
are details of an Iranian led program to
convert Hezbollah missiles into
precision guided weapons using
components brought in by land sea and
air it's warning Lebanon's government to
take action will be held responsible
we're determined to thwart this
dangerous program the aim of the
publication today is to clarify that we
will not stand aside and allow our
enemies to arm themselves with fatal
weaponry I told them this week be
careful and I repeat today in Arabic
neither by lack Hezbollah's leader
Hassan Nasrallah has denied precision
missiles are being manufactured inside
Lebanon he says Israel has in recent
days breached the rules of engagement in
place since the last war between Israel
and Lebanon in 2006 I say to the Israeli
army on the border from tonight stand
guard and wait for us he was speaking
shortly after two drones came down in a
Hezbollah stronghold in Beirut one of
them exploding there have been reports
that an important component of
Hezbollah's missile system was damaged
the Israeli army has remained silent on
the issue
Israel has for years been targeting
Iranian interests in Syria last weekend
it said it prevented a multiple drone
attack from inside the country by
launching an air strike that killed two
Hezbollah fighters there the United
States recently confirmed that Israel
was also carrying out airstrikes inside
Iraq targeting Iran's missile supply
route there but the more widespread and
more admitted Israel's actions become
the more risk that its adversaries feel
compelled to retaliate risking in turn a
broader escalation that's aligned
Israel's prime minister fighting an
election and once again promoting his
ability to keep his Raley's safe has
long tried not to cross this week he
told nasrallah by name to calm down
I think this Amir absolutely does not
want
military confrontation I think the call
to calm down was you know reflected that
on the other hand I think the feeling
and it's beyond attorney I think the
feeling in Israel is you cannot have
Iran which is declared ly interested in
the demise of Israel to deepen its
military capabilities just across Israel
northern border for now on that border
the wait continues for Hezbollah to make
its next move
Harry Fawcett al Jazeera West Jerusalem